es ist wieder soweit wissenschaft 2009
10 was waren dieses jahr die größten
ereignisse die wichtigsten erkenntnisse
und was waren die verteilten fehlschläge
orange communications das craft warum
werden wir uns in vielen jahren noch an
dieses 2009/10 erinnern
diese frage habe ich wissenschaftlern
wissens youtuber und journalisten
gestellt und das hier sind ihre
antworten
[Musik]
marius anschließenden dank ist da direkt
das erste mal dabei sein da ab und mein
highlight 2009 10 war keine neue
entdeckung sondern eher eine neue
entwicklung und zwar ist so viele
verschiedene technologien wirklich in
den mainstream angekommen sind ich will
zum beispiel ein gutes beispiel dafür
sind die pigs dieses jahr wurde so viel
wie noch nie zuvor in deutschland über
die pace gesprochen und sich die leute
haben dazu beitragen und richtig gemacht
ich habe ja zum beispiel auch ein dipp
von einem youtuber umgestellt wo er eine
bifi ist was dann auch ein bisschen so
einen kleinen skandal will ich etwas
sagen erzeugt hat und so weiter und so
fort das heißt solche technologien die
eigentlich nur sehr in der szene sagt
mir unterwegs waren sind jetzt langsam
mainstream gewonnen meine meinung nach
die interessanteste entwicklung in diese
richtung ist dass wir endlich ein
produkt in unserem alltag haben auf der
ganzen welt
ich freue mich bestimmt was ich damit
meine und zwar die instagram filter und
ich finde man sieht jetzt schon das
potenzial hinter dieser ganz technologie
denn facebook hat ja tatsächlich einen
liter zur verfügung gestellt mit denen
jeder selbst in den eigenen kasten quasi
erstellen kann und das finde ich ist
schon eine sehr sehr sehr coole sache
das was mir und ich freue mich auf ein
spannendes 2020 dass jetzt die
lithium-ionen-batterie meiner kamera in
der speichertechnologie die inzwischen
in allen möglichen mobilen geräten
steckt und aus unserem alltag kaum noch
wegzudenken ist
dabei hat ihnen ziemlich langen weg
hinter sich in den siebzigern
entwickelte stanley wollte ihm die erste
wiederaufladbaren lithium batterie mit
titanium die sulfid in der kathode und
metallischem lithium in der anode und
ein potenzial von zwei gold was schon
ziemlich hoch war und einige jahre
daraufhin setzte john goodman hat dann
das kartenmaterial durch kobalt oxid und
verdoppelte damit sogar das elektrischen
potenziale und deutlich sicherer und
auch öfter wieder aufladbar wurde sie
dann als akira hoshino und später das
metallische lithium in der anode durch
petrolkoks ersetzte in dem sich die
lithium ionen einlagern können ohne
chemisch damit zu reagieren
so was hat das jetzt mit diesem video zu
tun
naja für die entwicklung der
lithium-ionen-batterie wurden diese drei
forscher jetzt mit dem chemie nobelpreis
2009 10 ausgezeichnet und haben ihn
letzte woche am 10
dezember in stockholm entgegen genommen
für mich die größte und coolste
wissenschaft story des jahres 2009 10
war die der bärtierchen auf dem mond im
april ist eine israelische sonde auf dem
mond abgestürzt dh die landung hat nicht
funktioniert die sonne ist kaputt
gegangen aber die sonde hatte
bergkirchen an bord mikroskopisch kleine
lebewesen die quasi alles überleben
können extreme hitze extreme kälte die
temperaturen im weltraum und auch den
absturz einer sonde das heißt auf dem
mond auf unserem trabanten gibt es jetzt
wahrscheinlich leben
die story verein für mich einfach alles
was wissenschaft ausmacht dem
pioniergeist überhaupt zum mond fliegen
zu wollen
das scheitern und vielleicht das wieder
versuchen irgendwie aliens die jetzt auf
dem mond leben ziemlich abgefahren herr
jakob hier vom kanal breaken lab und
mainz 1 moment 2009 10 war das hier das
ist die studie vom rat für kulturelle
bildung zum thema youtube und da kam
erst mal raus dass 86 prozent der
schülerinnen und schüler youtube nutzen
und über die hälfte dieser gruppe
geplant dass die youtube auch zum lernen
und vor allem je älter die befragten
wurden desto mehr haben sie das zum
lernen genutzt und das nicht erst mal
ziemlich cool war das heißt dass das was
etwas meile was minister wissen zu
wollen wir machen euch wie ganz sinnvoll
ist ein ergebnis der studie war
tatsächlich auch dass die befragten das
gefühl haben dass sie auf youtube mehr
lernen und vor allem interessanter
lernen und was ich toll finde daran ist
wir haben in deutschland ein großes
problem wir haben sehr viel ungleichheit
und youtube videos sind frei verfügbar
das heißt ich habe das gefühl dass man
mit wissens videos auf youtube
tatsächlich ein stück weit diese
ungleichheit überwinden kann und das
finde ich total toll und deswegen war es
tatsächlich mainz 1 moment 2009 10 30
diese studie gelesen habe und ja ich
gebe zu dass ich damit wahrscheinlich
alleine war
nein wissenschaftsjahr 2009 10 sie diese
debatte anfang diesen jahres erinnert
euch vielleicht war gerade frisch das
dass diese fahrverbot kommen können soll
und dann gab es eine stellungnahme von
zwei jungen ernsten und zwei ingenieuren
unterzeichnet von über 100 anderen
wissenschaftlern dass die grenzwerte für
stickoxid belastung in der luft
katsch sein so wie sie aktuell sind
unter stickoxide gar nicht so schädlich
sind wie angenommen ein argument war
damals und naja ich als ballon erst hab
noch nie gesehen dass jemand an
luftverschmutzung gestorben ist
an rauchen schon aber einsatz
verschmutzung okay es kann dann
irgendwann raus dass diese stellungnahme
an sich war nicht richtig regent war und
dass sich auch dieser art gerechnet
hatte um ein paar nullen jedenfalls hat
dieser bericht sowohl in der politik als
auch in den medien damals riesenwellen
geschlagen und das ist natürlich ein
problem denn bei solchen fehlern leidet
das vertrauen in die wissenschaft aber
auch das vertrauen in die medien und das
ist natürlich fatal
mein persönliches wissenschaftliches
highlight im jahr 2009 10 war die
bekanntgabe dass die mission aida der
esa und der nasa nun die nötigen
finanziellen mittel zugesagt bekommen
hat um endlich auf den weg gebracht zu
werden
diese mission wird erstmals in der
geschichte versuchen einen asteroiden
aus seiner bahn zu lenken indem eine
sonde auf ihm explodiert
dadurch sollen wertvolle erkenntnisse
gewonnen werden um im notfall einen
asteroiden daran hindern zu können auf
unserer erde einzuschlagen
der esa generaldirektor jan wörner sagte
mit drastischen worten wir wollen nicht
durch einen asteroiden aussterben
tatsächlich könnte die menschheit durch
den einschlag eines mehrere kilometer
großen asteroiden aussterben so wie
einst die dinosaurier vor 66 millionen
jahren deshalb ist diese mission enorm
wichtig für die zukunft unserer
menschheit kanal taktisch und die sache
die ich 2009 10 am meisten gefeiert habe
ist etwas das schon länger bekannt ist
als ich auf der welt bin
denn 2009 10 haben literally zig tausend
wissenschaftler einen appell an die
mehrheit bezüglich der globalen
erwärmung gesendet es gibt dabei um
unser aller wohl empfinden und das sind
nicht irgendwelche meinungen dienen da
widersprochen wird sondern es sind
wissenschaftliche fakten die geleugnet
werden und deshalb war so ein weg buch
wie von den scientists future auf jeden
fall notwendig die sache ist die hat das
ausgereicht ich denke leider nicht also
wird da noch eine menge
aufklärungsarbeit notwendig sein leider
am 10 april 2009 10 war soweit jahre
lang hatten wir darauf gewartet denn die
daten lagen schon seit geraumer zeit vor
der klicks um zehn cent fiction hatten
wir immer wieder darüber berichtet aber
es hat er seine zeit gebraucht bis die
unglaublichen datenmengen durchgerechnet
waren mehrere petabyte waren das also
tausende terabyte wahnsinn
das erste bild eines schwarzen lochs
noch nie wurde ein so scharfes bild von
einem schwarzen noch gemacht hier ist es
also das zentrale schwarze loch in der
fernen galaxie messier 87 eine absolute
sensation das supermassereiche schwarze
loch hat sechs milliarden sonnenmassen
und das bild sieht genau so aus wie es
erwartet wurde
wir sehen die heiße akkretionsscheibe um
das loch herum in die materie sturz
durch eine geschwindigkeit von etwa 3,6
millionen kilometer pro stunde
unglaublich aufgeheizt wird und deshalb
so hell leuchtet 100 milliarden
kilometer durchmesser hat der schwarze
schatten in der mitte der
ereignishorizont des schwarzen lochs der
alles licht und alle materie hinter sich
verschwinden
also mein wissenschaftlicher höhepunkt
des jahres 2009 10 ist eine arbeit die
in nature erschienen ist von olivia
trotzen sie energie experten auf
evolution und sie präsentierte ein wie
ich finde unglaublich tolles modell wie
man verstehen kann wie die verschiedenen
evolutionsforscher planeten zu
charakterisieren sind sie sagt nämlich
es gibt fünf phasen es beginnt mit
geochemischer energie das heißt das
leben hat sich zunächst einmal
entwickelt aus geochemischen quellen
dann kommt die photosynthese am anfang
nur die an ob sie gene also wohl noch
keinen sauerstoff entsteht dann kommt
die oxygen es photosynthese dass die
nächste die nächste energiequelle und
damit springt das leben praktisch über
den gesamten planeten und dann geht's
weiter nämlich fleisch und eier fleisch
ist praktisch das was sie bezeichnet als
in pflanzen und tieren gespeicherte
sonnenenergie und dann kommt das tier
dass das feuerwerk und das sind die wir
sind in der lage mit hilfe von feuer
unsere nahrung so vor zu verdauen dass
wir unglaubliche mengen an energie
aufnehmen können und sich daraus
evolutionär auch der grund für die
entwicklung des hirns ableiten lässt das
heißt die tatsache dass wir überall
diese energiequellen auf unserem
planeten verfügen die alle ja noch da
sind also biochemie das sonnenlicht in
verschiedenen varianten fleisch und
feuer
das hat dazu geführt dass das leben sich
auf unserem planeten zu einer solchen
vielfalt entwickelt hat und das in einem
artikel zusammenzubringen geochemie
photosynthese also biochemie bis hin zu
zur soziologie also sozialwissenschaft
und geisteswissenschaften mit den
naturwissenschaften in einem großen bild
zu vereinigen das war für mich das
highlight des jahres 2009
danke an alle die mitgemacht haben ist
immer wieder toll das zusehen dass ich
alle dabei sein und auch schön meinen
zuschauern zu zeigen was es noch alles
da draußen gibt welche vielen coolen
wissens kanäle es da draußen gibt die
links zu den kanälen findet ihr
natürlich alle unten in der video
beschreibung wenn euch also ein kanal
gefallen hat dann auf jeden fall da
hingehen und abonnieren
um im nächsten jahr noch ein bisschen
schlauer zu werden das war noch lange
nicht alles dieses jahr ist in der
wissenschaft eine menge passiert
deswegen hier mal eine auswahl meiner
wichtigsten momente
dritter januar china landet auf der
dunklen seite des mondes und beginnt sie
mit einem rover zu erkunden die changi
vier mission ist die erste überhaupt die
auf dieser seite des mondes landet
fünfzehnter mal wissenschaftler
verkünden dass sie einen lebenden
organismus kreiert haben dessen dna
komplett menschengemacht ist
die bakterien können sich reproduzieren
und stellen womöglich eine neue
lebensform da fünfundzwanzigster juni
die planetary society bringt laut
zeltner erfolgreich in die umlaufbahn
der erde
das 32 quadratmeter große sonnensegel
soll beweisen dass sich eine sonde
allein mit dem strahlend druck der
sonnenkraft fortbewegen kann
dreiundzwanzigster august australische
und chinesische wissenschaftler
berichten von der ersten erfolgreichen
teleportation von dreidimensionalen
cubes die komplexer sind als
zweidimensionale cubes elfter september
wissenschaftler entdecken einen
exoplaneten auf dem es wasserdampf zu
geben scheint der planet k2 strich 18b
ist 110 lichtjahre entfernt und der
bisher einzige bekannte planet außerhalb
unseres sonnensystems der eine
atmosphäre wasser und die richtige
temperatur für flüssiges wasser besitzt
zehnter dezember forscher der nasa
berichten dass große mengen von eis
direkt unter der oberfläche des mars zu
finden sein könnten über das jahr hinweg
haben wissenschaftler außerdem immer
wieder erstaunliche aber oft auch sehr
beängstigende erkenntnisse über das
klima und unsere umwelt veröffentlicht
so verliert grünland inzwischen jährlich
286 milliarden tonnen eis vor 20 jahren
war es nicht einmal ein fünftel davon
das intergovernmental panel on climate
change ein pc veröffentlichte im
september einen bericht in dem unter
anderem das steigen des meeresspiegels
bis 2100 um zehn zentimeter nach oben
korrigiert wurde
neuer stand 1,1 meter ein un-bericht
warnte außerdem davor dass in den
nächsten jahrzehnten 500.000 bis eine
millionen tier und pflanzenarten vor dem
aussterben bedroht sind
nach dem ebola für tausende tote sorgte
und im juli von der whu als globale
gesundheitsbedrohung deklariert wurde
konnten zwei medikamente erfolgreich in
der demokratischen republik kongo
eingesetzt werden mit dem virus neu
infizierte personen haben durch diese
antikörper cocktails eine bis zu 90
prozentige überlebenschance ein riesiger
erfolg
schaut euch hier oben gerne an was 2018
die größten ereignisse der wissenschaft
waren und falls ihr das gefühl habt dass
ihr freunde habt denen dieses video
gefallen könnte dann teilt es gerne mit
ihnen denn weihnachten ist ja
bekanntlich die zeit des teilens und
damit wünsche ich euch schöne festtage
und eine entspannte zeit mit der familie
wie immer bleibt neugierig patrick
[Musik]